[Musica]
quanto siamo importanti per l'arte Quali
sono le figure importanti nel mondo
dell'arte l'artista Innanzitutto senza
chi la genera L'arte non Potrebbe
esistere l'artista crea l'opera esprime
il proprio pensiero e lo manifesta
quindi il primo attore dell'Arte è
l'artista senza l'artista l'arte non
esisterebbe E su questo non c'è alcun
dubbio
da sempre però esistono altre figure
importanti nel mondo dell'arte e i
committenti per esempio sono stati
grandi committenti potenti grandi
signori la chiesa a creare per primi del
guadagno intorno alla figura degli
artisti e alle loro opere la chiesa
Innanzitutto va detto Ecco perché in
Italia Abbiamo così tanta arte Grazie a
Dio è proprio il caso di dirlo quindi
senza l'artista forse non esisterebbe
l'arte ma senza grandi committenti forse
non sarebbe gestita della grande arte
una avrebbe potuto essere così diffusa
poi
nel tempo ci sono state altre figure che
sono diventate sempre più figure chiave
nel sistema arte perché un giorno è nato
il mercato dell'arte e quindi gli
artisti non dipingevano più soltanto per
i privati o la chiesa ma spinti Dai
mecenati che investivano su di loro e le
opere venivano esposte nelle gallerie ed
ecco qui la nuova figura del gallerista
e quindi invece nati mercanti d'arte
galleristi collezionisti sono tutte
figure importantissime senza le quali
Probabilmente oggi non conosceremo come
conosciamo l'arte moderna e
contemporanea senza un po' Alexander per
dire probabilmente Modigliani non
sapremo davvero chi è
Alexander che fu suo mentore nonché suo
anche unica fonte di sostentamento per
molto tempo il suo primo collezionista
oppure senza la grande mostra degli
impressionisti la prima grande mostra
che fece un successo incredibile e che
fece fatta Grazie all'allora
famosissimo fotografo nadar che mise a
disposizione gli spazi del suo studio
gratuitamente proprio per questo gruppo
di artisti che altrimenti sarebbero
passati in sordina e forse
l'impressionismo non avrebbe fatto così
impressione o comunque non sarebbe stato
così importante da influenzare tutta
l'arte a venire del Novecento
e ancora mi vengono in mente gli
studiosi i critici e sono importanti
perché sono loro che fanno devono fare
Sono deputati a fare le valutazioni le
perizie sono quelli che
in pratica dovrebbero garantirci Non
sempre però ci provano Che un'opera di
Raffaello sia veramente di Raffaello e
non magari di un ragazzo della sua
bottega Raffaello ha passato di là solo
a dare quattro pennellate e poi sono
quelli che devono divulgare diffondere
l'arte comunicarla insieme alla figura
più recente dei curatori di curatori
critici più o meno figure sovrapponibili
loro hanno il compito di organizzare le
mostre e però soprattutto di organizzare
di curare
la narrazione perché funzioni il
percorso espositivo
e poi Ecco A proposito di esposizione mi
vengono in mente non si possono
dimenticare i musei e chi li dirige che
siano pubblici o che siano privati a
proposito di privati le fondazioni
importantissime perché sostengono l'arte
arrivano Laddove le istituzioni
pubbliche a volte non arriva
Beh
Queste secondo me sono più o meno le
tutte le categorie Anzi Vabbè se chiedo
scusa se ho dimenticato qualcuno Anzi se
c'è qualcuno fra di voi che appartiene a
una delle categorie eventualmente da me
dimenticate vi chiedo di alzarvi in
piedi e dirmi ci siamo anche noi
nessuno lo fa
nessuno si alza in piedi e dice ci siamo
anche noi
Eppure dovreste farlo tutti perché ci
siamo anche noi gli spettatori perché
gli spettatori alla fine sono i veri
destinatari dell'opera d'arte Eh sì cioè
il pittore non è che si fa un quadro per
appenderlo in casa perché lo fa perché
qualcuno lo veda
Sì magari lo fa anche perché qualcuno
gliela commissionato però alla fine i
committenti galleristi collezionisti che
cosa diventano diventano spettatori e i
musei perché fanno le mostre perché gli
spettatori vadano a vedere dell'arte i
curatori uguale perché organizzano in un
certo modo ehm le mostre perché gli
spettatori vadano a vederle e possono
goderne o trarne un insegnamento insomma
Cioè alla fine a parte l'artista la
figura più importante del mondo
dell'arte siamo noi gli spettatori
ragazzi senza di noi tutti i disoccupati
è i musei chiudono direttori a casa
curatori idem i galleristi non avrebbero
più i soldi per pagare la galleria
qua tutti guadagnano Comunque io pago
vi rendete conto Vabbè allora Ma qui la
domanda è Ma se siamo così importanti
per il mondo dell'arte
perché non abbiamo voce in capitolo e
questa è una bella domanda
C'è da dire che l'arte segue un po' le
sue dinamiche che poi sono quelle del
suo mercato e anche qui andrebbe
sottolineato che non tutti gli
spettatori sono anche collezionisti cioè
poi magari mi sbaglio Eh però Sfido
chiunque di voi ad avere a casa o
un'opera del suo artista preferito che
ne so un picasso un Van Gogh da lì anzi
se c'è qualcuno magari mi sbaglio che ha
uno di queste opere d'arte a casa Siete
pregiati di lasciare l'indirizzo
all'ingreda Non per altro che mi
piacerebbe vederla quest'opera Comunque
vabbè ehm Tornando a noi perché
Se siamo così importanti non abbiamo
voce in capitolo e questo è anche un po'
il destino del fruitore perché io vado
allo stadio proprio il biglietto ma non
è che posso fare la formazione
e la fa chi guadagna non io che pago
siamo 160 milioni
commissari tecnici Come si dice da
sempre ma alla fine nessuno può fare la
formazione la fa chi è pagato per farla
ed è giusto anche così perché
vinciamo gli europei No in effetti No
perché rimaniamo ancora fuori dai
mondiali
Va bene ok scusate la divagazione
calcistica Però effettivamente forse non
è stata così inutile perché sapete
perché secondo me il pubblico non ha
voce in capitolo
perché spesso il pubblico stesso credi
di non essere all'altezza credi di non
poter parlare di un tema alto è
importante come l'arte con la stessa
leggerezza con cui si affronta il calcio
come mi piace l'arte ma non ne so nulla
attaccio Come mi appassiona quest'opera
ma non mi sento autorevole Fermi tutti
perché per parlare di qualsiasi cosa
bisogna essere autorevoli Beh dipende
Bisogna vedere se vogliamo pontificare
sull'efficacia o meno di un vaccino
vogliamo fare discorsi puntuali sulla
situazione Geopolitica Magari sì ma ci
sono tantissimi argomenti per cui
essenzialmente una Questione di feeling
non bisogna avere paura di dire
quest'opera mi piace non mi piace o
non ne so niente non la conosco
non la capisco perché
l'arte non va capita O meglio non è il
punto essenziale il punto essenziale è
sentirla feeling davvero e non un'opera
d'arte ognuno può vedere capire sentire
quello che vuole poi L'arte è fatta di
simboli che si possono leggere in mille
modi diversi
per esempio
se qualcuno va a vedere la Gioconda E
sostiene che sia triste chi sono io per
dire ma come questo famoso sorrisino ma
non vedi che serenità
La verità
è che i tempi sono cambiati non è più
vero che noi ignoranti non possiamo dire
la nostra possiamo eccome e
potenzialmente possiamo farla decine
centinaia migliaia di persone Grazie ai
mezzi che la rete oggi ci fornisce Sì
possiamo raccontare l'arte possiamo dire
ciò che ci piace sostenere gli artisti
che ci piacciono e Sì possiamo fare
tutto questo
e magari influenzare Nel nostro piccolo
meno piccolo e sistemarti prima potevano
farlo soltanto gli studiosi sui loro
libri polverosi
io da qualche anno racconto l'arte sui
social o qualche decina di migliaia di
persone che mi seguono insieme a me lo
fanno altre persone che hanno
altrettanti follower e
siamo amici più che colleghi Uniti dalla
stessa passione per l'arte che appunto
ci unisce e la nostra voce il nostro
punto di vista è sempre più importante
siamo il pubblico influente
poi vabbè Noi abbiamo deciso di farne un
lavoro di occuparci di questo ma sarebbe
veramente importantissimo che lo
facessero tutti quelli che amano l'arte
dico tutti perché non bisogna
sottovalutare la forza comunicativa
dell'immagine sui social Oggi no E
quindi Se amate l'arte se fa parte della
vostra vita della vostra quotidianità
perché non provate ad andare in un museo
al posto che fare foto così magari
Potete provare a interagire con l'opera
a raccontare che cosa vedete che cosa
sentite che cosa vi trasmette
quell'opera d'arte Ecco magari non
diventerà virale perché poi L'arte è una
cosa seria anzi In questo caso forse
seriosa Però vabbè in quanto tale almeno
sta grammabile però davvero non conta
avere tanti numeri tanti follower conta
essere in tanti e far sentire la nostra
voce
e trasmettere di dire agli altri quello
che è giusto che è sbagliato cos'è arte
cosa non è arte
Eh sì
Cioè dovremmo veramente inondare Social
con immagini e punti di vista opinioni
senza avere paura senza avere paura
perché quello che conta nella fruizione
dell'arte davvero e la sensazione e la
sensazione è sempre giusta
come dicevo prima Oh ma se io La
Gioconda la vedo triste la vedo triste
Non so cosa volete che vi dica e magari
vado lì mi metto vicino al Gioconda
faccio una faccia tristissima
scatto un selfie caption secondo voi chi
è più triste delle due
questo modo di approcciarsi all'arte
crea un dubbio crea un engagement
l'opera e il vostro il vostro stato
d'animo davvero e
possiamo veramente farlo tutti
L'importante è farlo
ma soprattutto Siamo gli spettatori
siamo importanti e
la cosa più importante di tutte una
smettere di avere paura di qualcosa di
cui abbiamo sempre avuto paura perché
veramente io negli anni ho potuto
constatare che la gente la cosa di cui
ha più paura in assoluto è parlare di
arte Ecco io ho smesso di avere paura
Fatelo anche voi anzi vi dico di più
questa sera Lo facciamo insieme perché
ho preparato un gioco perché ho deciso
di finire questo Ted in maniera concreta
perché va bene che i Ted sono parole
Appunto però Verba volant come abbiamo
detto le immagini sono importantissime
nella vostra bag avete queste tre
immagini sono tre opere d'articoniche e
io vi invito a tirare fuori i vostri
cellulari subito fatelo subito tutti
perché è tardi poi mi buttano giù dal
palco e avete queste Tre immagini
sceglietene Una quella che vi piace di
più Uhm Fatevi però un selfie Okay una
foto Provate a interagire fate quello
che volete e Scrivete quello che vi
suscita Qual è la sensazione che provate
eh Mentre voi lo fate Io vi voglio solo
dire un'ultima cosa ci sono questi
hashtag che sono importantissimi dovete
descriverli e pubblicarli sui vostri
Social state una storia un post quello
che volete
vi faccio però notare che
c'è la parola controluce fra quegli
hashtag e se l'opera d'arte è in luce
Noi siamo in controluce ma del nostro
controluce possiamo essere illuminanti
[Applauso]